ever ask yourself what would showgirls
be like if it was pg-13 I sure have
[Music]
showgirls - aka burlesque burlesque is
the story of a young girl with dreams
played by Christina Aguilera and her
bitter washed-up stage / bar owner /
burlesque owner / mother figure played
by Sonny Bono's wife now if you think
for a second this is just gonna be a
run-of-the-mill girl from a small town
goes to the big city to chase our dreams
kind of movie you're right actually the
big difference between Christina
Aguilera in this movie and most girls
who chase their dreams as most girls who
go to the city to chase their dreams
find out how hard it is to actually
chase your dreams so they end up drying
up somewhere in some degrading job where
guys whistle at him and grab their asses
forever never to be remembered in the
boulevard of broken dreams but Christina
Aguilera in this movie she was ahead of
the curve she was like you know if I aim
low and I make plan B my plan a if I
achieve plan B which is usually the
fallback of failure I've achieved my
dream you're a pioneer of low
expectations Christina we salute you
this movie is exactly what you'd expect
it has every cliche that a movie like
this has seemingly average and relatable
yet way too hot to be a seemingly
average and relatable character check
old stubborn mentor type check
insignificant yet likable romantic
interest check the bitter rival who's
mad that the new girls become the new
star check there you go
Christina Aguilera's acting it was okay
in some parts it was crap another she
sings well though and she looks better
she's pretty odd and that's pretty much
the point of this movie the guilty
pleasure of seeing hot women dance
around showing all the Victoria's
Secrets and in that they did their jobs
perfectly and then they're sure who's
pretty much gone from looking like the
mom and mask to the Sun and mask with a
lot of Botox and Photoshop best part of
this movie stanley tucci hands down the
guy owens this movie I mean he steals
this movie every one of the best lines
in this movie the best moments in this
movie the best character in this movie
Stanley Tucci in the very best way I can
describe it burlesque is like if
showgirls was busted down to pg-13 and
had a kid with coyote ugly which was
then painted up like Moulin Rouge so I
would say this movie would be OK in that
guilty-pleasure kind of way and might
even be relevant if you're drunk
yeah and now as a party and we didn't
have access to porn Maxim Google Images
pretty much any in all corners of the
porn ridden Internet
yeah
Naza party I mean catchy music hot women
cliched plot and a singer in a starring
role and exceptions to the rule about
the singer in the starring role part
however there is a really good line in
this movie said by Stanley Tucci I mean
go figure but it says something like
everything has a shelf life even
opportunity of words to live by know
that life lessons brought to you by the
movie based on page 38 of the
Frederick's of Hollywood catalog but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more
[Music]